The next case delves into one of the most opaque sections of the uniform
commercial code in is hung filled opinion in textile unlimited versus a BMH
judge.
Thomas of the ninth circuit had to grapple with the battle of the forms in which
two companies send each other form documents with incompatible terms and
conditions.
Uh,
the case involved textile unlimited,
a yarn distributor in California and a Bmh,
a yarn manufacturer in Georgia.
The two companies regularly did business with textile by new yarn from a BMH 38
times.
You can see some of textiles yarn here.
Each time textile sent a purchase order to a Bmh via a broker,
and then a BMH would send an invoice and a,
an order acknowledgement that contained an arbitration clause stating that any
dispute would have to be arbitrated.
Back in Atlanta on the 39th order textile received what it claimed was defective
yarn.
And so it refuse to pay a BMH set up an arbitration in Atlanta,
but textile sued in federal court in California to prevent are the arbitration
from going forward.
We're looking at the opinion from the Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals.
The federal appeals court that covers California and other western states.
Judge Thomas must decide whether the arbitration clause is enforceable even if
textile unlimited never explicitly agreed to it.
Let's walk through the key sections of the uniform commercial code a section two
two oh seven to see how judge Thomas reaches his conclusion that the arbitration
clause is not enforceable because it's not part of the contract between the two
parties.
Subsection one deals with the basic question of whether there's a contract in
the these battle of the form context where two companies are sending back and
forth forms with conflicting terms.
When confronting a two two oh seven question,
it's important to separately address different routes to whether a contract is
formed and separately.
What are the terms of the contract if it is formed?
Two Two oh seven lays out different ways of forming the contract and different
ways can produce different terms.
Section one first tells us that an expression of acceptance can operate as an
acceptance even if that expression states terms that are additional to or
different from those that are offered.
That by itself tells us that the UCC rejects the common laws mirror image rule
in the Minneapolis and St Louis Railway case,
when the offeree made an expression of acceptance that stated different terms,
the expression was considered a counteroffer,
not an acceptance,
but two two,
Oh oh seven,
one tells us that non-matching acceptances can operate.
They do operate as acceptances and therefore can form contracts.
Second subsection one says that a Ritter written confirmation of an earlier oral
agreement can also operate as an acceptance even if the confirmation states
different terms.
So if a buyer and seller agree orally to a big order on the telephone and then
one sends a written confirmation in part to satisfy the statute of frauds,
the confirmation can operate as an acceptance even if this confirmation includes
different or additional terms.
But subsection one also includes the,
uh,
the famous unless clause,
which tells us that the two ways of creating a contract,
the non-matching acceptance route.
And the non-matching confirmation route that these two routes are not effective.
If acceptance is expressly made conditional on a scent to additional or
different terms.
The unless question boils down to whether the offer reis form says that the
acceptance is conditional on the offer awards accepting the uh,
the new or additional terms.
If that's the case then the writing does not operate as an acceptance but
operates merely as a counteroffer.
In this case,
a Bmh,
the offeree,
uh,
had a form that is quite explicit sellers willingness to sell yarn to you is
conditioned on your acceptance of these terms of sale.
So a BMH is forum expressedly triggers the unless clause there is therefore no
contract based on two two,
Oh oh seven one.
It's interesting to note that in this context,
textile unlimited,
his receipt of the yarn wasn't an acceptance of new terms as judge Thomas notes.
We don't want a rule where whoever sends the last form wins.
So if subsection one tells us that the contract has been entered into based on
the forms,
subsection two tells us what the actual contents of the contract are.
If it is formed under subsection one,
it doesn't apply in this case because there was no sub section one formation,
but it's worth familiarizing yourself with what the terms would be a under
subsection two.
The first sentence of subsection two tells us that additional terms are to be
construed as proposals for additions to the contract.
Remember the contract was formed with non-matching terms,
but according to the first sentence of subsection to those new terms are not
included in the contract but are an offer to modify a if the other side agrees
to this modification proposal.
The second sentence,
however,
lays out a different treatment of contracts formed under subsection one that are
between two merchants by default.
The new terms on the offer,
reis form become part of the contract if the formation is between two merchants
except uh,
under three listed,
uh,
conditions.
Number one,
the offer expressly limits acceptance to the terms of the offer.
Number two,
if the additional terms materially change the agreement.
And number three,
if the other side,
uh,
objects.
In this case,
if there had been a contract formed under subsection one,
the arbitration clause would probably have been valid because the parties are
merchants and textile textiles offered didn't express Li limit acceptance to its
terms of the offer.
And crucially the court probably would find that the additional arbitration term
isn't a material alteration.
And finally,
textile unlimited never objected to this arbitration clause.
Many times the question of whether non-matching terms between merchants come
into the contract is going to be governed by the Schicks Shakespearean question
to be or not to be.
Did the terms materially alter the agreement?
Subsection three of two two oh seven tells us what happens if there's no
formation under subsection one,
but the parties conduct based on what they do.
Evidence is that they believed they were in a contract.
If the Parties Act as if there is a contract by shipping and accepting the
goods,
uh,
so there can still be a contract based on their conduct.
And secondly,
it tells us what terms to apply when we're going to have formation via party
conduct.
And that's those terms are going to be governed by what's called the knockout
doctrine.
So under the knockout doctrine,
we remove any terms on which the two companies forms do not agree and then
supplement what what's left over with the default rules from the UCC as applied
to this case.
The arbitration agreement is not in both forms and so the it would be knocked
out.
We strike it out.
It isn't part of the contract and and so the court will not enforce it.
Uh,
sub section three provides both a third route to non-matching formation and a
knockout rule for determining what terms will be in the contract.
Subjects in three is important because in a classic battle of the forms,
there will not be subsection one formation because the forms will always demand
additional assent.
So the head,
unless clause will be triggered.
The drafters of two two oh seven hoped that the knockout rule would put a thumb
on the scale in favor of the UCC defaults under the common laws mirror image
rule.
The last form tended to win the battle of the forms you see under the mirror
image rule.
Each writing exchanged between the buyer and the seller failed to form a
contract because it was not a mirror image.
Each writing was therefore just a counter offer.
The seller forms would often restrict warranties and the virus forms would not
restrict the warranties.
Each non-matching form would merely be a counter offer.
The seller would normally then when the battle of the forms because the seller
would send the last form with its shipment and the buyer would be deemed to
accept this last form,
this last counter offer by taking physical possession of the goods.
So under the common law and the mirror image rule,
the seller's form restricting warranties would normally govern,
uh,
the terms of the contract.
But subsection three,
sought to fix that by saying that when the conduct of the parties evidence the
formation of a contract,
that the,
that conflicting terms drop out and the default warranties,
uh,
and other terms would govern,
whenever there was a disagreement.
So imagine this hypothetical ABC sends an order to x,
Y,
Z to buy 100 widgets,
Xyz sends an invoice and then the goods,
the invoice contains a provision saying only quote,
there will be no punitive damages based on this sale.
ABC does not say anything.
The punitive damages provision,
the widgets turned out to be defective and ABC,
suse,
are they bound by the punitive damages provision?
Well,
the answer is probably yes.
In this situation,
the term concerning,
uh,
the punitive damages is incorporated probably into the contract first.
We see that under subsection one,
there is a contract because the non-matching invoice operates as an acceptance
and x,
Y Z's form doesn't condition it's acceptance on ABC's assent to additional
terms.
So we have sub section one formation.
We then look to subsection two to find out what the terms of this formed
contract are.
So under subsection two,
it says that the contracts between merchants,
which we have here,
the new terms become binding in London unless one of the three conditions apply.
Well ABC didn't object and uh,
and the court likely wouldn't find a material material alteration in this
prohibition on punitive damages since we'll learn later on in the course or
actually in contracts to that punitive damages usually aren't allowed and and
contract cases.
So the new condition is likely to be found to be binding.
But the big fight,
again we'll be to be or not to be,
whether the provision was a material alteration.
There are three main takeaways from this battle of forms discussion.
The first is that in transactions between merchants,
new terms on the he is form generally do become part of the contract unless the
offer or objects or the Ma these new terms material or materially alter the
agreement.
And when the two parties don't ever come to agreement based on the forms,
courts apply under subsection three of two two oh seven,
the knockout doctrine.
So the actual contract is any terms that appear on both forms together with the
default rules from the UCC.
And finally,
when analyzing two,
two oh seven separately,
uh,
it's important that you separately analyze what terms govern from the question
of whether a contract is formed by one of the three routes than non-matching
acceptance route.
That non-matching confirmation route and the conduct of the parties route.